but first a story that has not received
nearly enough attention
in cities across the country prosecutors
and lawmakers are working frantically to
make life worse for normal people
and easier for thugs and armed robbers
we told you about new york's new bail
law the one that lets criminals back
onto the streets
immediately after being caught not
surprisingly crime has surged
this has shocked nobody except maybe
chris cuomo's brother who runs the state
and who's responsible for it now there's
this sad story
in 2018 new york resident wilma
rodriguez was brutally assaulted by two
members of
ms-13 after he tried to protect two boys
they were threatening
rodriguez agreed to testify against his
attackers in court as good citizens do
that decision cost him his life on
sunday rodriguez was beaten to death
outside his home
until recently rodriguez would have been
protected by new york law
which allowed prosecutors to conceal the
names of witnesses until shortly before
trial for their safety
but a new law this one passed to help
criminal defendants
required prosecutors to turn over
rodriguez's name to the gang members
lawyers almost immediately gang members
started harassing rodriguez
this week they killed him that's what
new york is like now
do the right thing and you could be
murdered by predators the government is
determined to protect
lunacy yes it is lunacy but it's not
confined to new york
in 2018 nancy pelosi attacked the
president for daring to call ms-13
members
animals according to pelosi trump was
more immoral than the gang members he
insulted
we're all god's children there's a spark
of divinity in every person
on earth and so when the president of
the united states says
about undocumented immigrants these
aren't people
these are animals
you have to wonder does he not believe
in the spark of divinity the dignity and
worth of every person
every day that you think you've seen it
all along comes another
manifestation of why their policies are
so inhumane
he's a sinner ms-13 are god's children
well vox did an entire video about how
really ms-13 were just misunderstood
high school students
decent hard-working kids maligned by a
racist media
when you think of the street gang ms-13
what do you see maybe something like
this
or this but what if i told you the
typical
ms-13 gang member in the u.s actually
looks like one of these young men
on facebook ms-13 members that i've been
following
are working after school jobs they're
living with their parents
they get around long island on bicycles
there's no indication that we're seeing
a bigger surge of ms-13 than we've
seen in the past fox wants you to calm
down
it was just a false alarm everything's
cool go back to bed those scary ms-13
gang members just a nightmare
except they weren't they're real ms-13
is an actual
organization it's a massive
transnational criminal organization
that's left behind a trail of bodies in
a number of countries over decades
three years ago we traveled to el
salvador to see where it all started
we visited a detention center in san
salvador where suspected ms-13 members
are being held before trial more than 50
men
packed in a single cell their backs to
us to avoid being identified
some seemed barely out of childhood
though in many cases they were covered
in gang tattoos a sign of their total
commitment
before long some of these guys may wind
up in la or long island
it's happening now what was your role in
the gang i was a soldier
a foot soldier what does that mean a
trigger man
a trigger man that means that i that
means to kill
how old were you when you first killed i
was 15 years old
that was my first homicide how many
people did you kill
i killed last time quite a few
quite a few a 15 year old committing
murder we have those in our country too
it's a sad fact it's something we should
be both horrified and ashamed of
crime and violence are the clearest
possible signs that a society isn't
functioning as it should
if they increase to a certain point
societies don't function at all and we
should be worried about that always
we ought to be doing all that we can to
build a place a country where people who
follow the law are rewarded
those who flouted are punished and above
all children can live in peace and
safety
they used to be obvious it's not obvious
anymore
at this moment there's a bill pending in
the congress called the new way
forward act it's received almost no
publicity and that's unfortunate
as well as revealing the legislation is
sponsored by 44
house democrats including ilhon omar and
alexandria casio cortez
it's roughly 4 400 words long that means
it's almost exactly as long as the us
constitution
like the constitution it's designed to
create a whole new country
the bill would entirely remi make our
immigration system with the explicit
purpose of ensuring that criminals are
able to move to the united states
and settle here permanently with
immunity you may think we're
exaggerating for effect but we're not
exaggerating not even a little bit
the new way forward act is the single
most radical piece of legislation we
have ever seen proposed in this country
ever it makes the green new deal look
like the status quo
the document produced by democrats to
promote the bill says this and we're
quoting it verbatim
convictions should not lead to
deportation end quote
now keep in mind we're not talking about
convictions for double parking or even
for dui
the bill targets felony convictions
serious crimes that could send you to
prison for years and should
a press release from congressman jesus
garcia of illinois is explicit about
this
garcia brags the bill will break the
quote prison to deportation pipeline
something most of us were for so how
does the bill do that
well under current u.s law legal u.s
immigrants can be deported if they
commit a quote aggravated felony or a
crime of moral turpitude that is a
vile depraved act like molesting
children
under the new way forward act crimes of
moral turpitude
are eliminated entirely as justification
for deportation
and the category of aggravated felony
gets eliminated too
so what does that mean consider this
under current law
immigrants who commit serious crimes
robbery to fraud to child
sexual abuse must be deported regardless
of the sentences they receive
other crimes less severe ones like
racketeering require deportation
if the perpetrator receives at least a
one year sentence
under this bill there will no longer be
any crime that automatically requires
deportation
none and one crime falsifying a passport
would be made
immune from deportation no matter what
because apparently 9 11 never even
happened
and we no longer care about fake
government documents by the way if you
just renewed your driver's license to
comply with the real id
act you must feel like an idiot because
immigrants are getting a pass you're not
under the proposed legislation for
crimes that would still allow
deportation the required prison sentence
would rise from one year to five years
we checked the bureau of justice
statistics according to federal data
crimes like car
theft fraud and weapons offenses all
carry average princeton sentences
of fewer than five years and that's just
looking at averages there are people who
commit rape
child abuse even manslaughter and get
sentences with fewer than five years
lots of them actually if the new way
forward act passes
immigrants who commit those crimes and
receive those sentences would remain
in this country and of course they will
be eligible for citizenship day one
too of course but even that is
understating the law's effect even a
five-year prison sentence wouldn't
necessarily be enough to trigger
deportation
the bill would grant sweeping new powers
to immigration judges allowing them to
nullify a deportation order
the only requirement for that is quote
the immigration judge
finds such an exercise of discretion
appropriate in pursuant of
humanitarian purposes to assure family
unity
or when it is otherwise in the public
interest talk about
open-ended in other words anti-american
immigration judges
and there are a lot of those in this
country would have a blank check to open
the borders
you would not be voting on this it would
happen anyway
is this shocking you yet because we're
just getting started
we read this proposed legislation
here's another point current u.s law
makes drug addiction grounds for
deportation because
why wouldn't it this bill would
eliminate that statute current law also
states that those who have committed
drug crimes abroad or quote
any crimes involving involving moral
turpitude are ineligible to immigrate
here
the new way forward act abolishes that
statute so a mexican drug cartel leader
could be released from prison
then freely come to america immediately
and if he wants he could come here
illegally
and it still wouldn't be a crime because
and you were waiting for this part
the bill also decriminalizes illegal
entry into america
even by those we've previously deported
otherwise you break our law
we send you out you come back you break
it again you can stay
according to a document promoting this
bill criminalizing illegal entry into
america is quote
white supremacist that's a quote white
supremacist
now by this point you're beginning to
wonder are we making this up
we're not making it up in fact we're
barely halfway through the bill
the legislation doesn't just make it
harder to deport illegal immigrants who
commit crimes
it doesn't just make it easier for
criminals to move here illegally though
it does both
the bill would also effectively abolish
all existing enforcement against illegal
immigration
to detain illegal immigrants ice would
have to prove in court that they are
dangerous or a flight risk
but of course ice wouldn't be allowed to
use a detainee's prior criminal behavior
as proof of danger that's banned
ice would have to overcome even more
hurdles if the detainee claims to be gay
or transgendered
if they're under 21 or if they can't
speak english an interpreter isn't
immediately available they get a pass in
other words
it would be much harder to arrest an
illegal alien in this country
than it is to arrest you they're the
protected class here
you're just some loser who's paying for
it all but believe it or not we save the
nuttiest part of this legislation for
last and here's what it is
what could be more destructive than
changing u.s law specifically
to allow rapists child molesters and
drug dealers to stay in america how
about this
using taxpayer money to bring deported
criminals
back into america that's right this bill
would not only abolish your right to
control who lives in your country
but it invents a brand new right
quote the right to come home it orders
the government to create a quote
pathway for those previously deported to
apply to return to their homes
and families in the united states as
long as they would have been eligible to
stay under the new law
it's retroactive in other words dhs must
spend taxpayer dollars
transporting convicted criminal illegal
aliens
back into the united states not making
this up so who would be eligible for
these flights
tens of thousands of people we kicked
out of this country for all kinds of
crimes
sexual abuse robbery assault drug
trafficking weapons trafficking human
trafficking
from 2002 to 2018 480
000 people were deported for illegal
entry or re-entry into america
and under this bill you'd have to buy
each of them a plane ticket to come home
those tickets alone would cost about a
billion dollars and that's before
democrats make you start paying for
these criminals free health care too
which they plan to do and have said so
the new way forward act fundamentally
inverts
every assumption you have about this
country under this legislation the
criminals are now the victims
law enforcement is a legitimate it's
racist just like the country you live in
just like you are and the only solution
is to get rid of both
america would be better off as a
borderless rest stop for the world's
predators and parasites that's the point
of this and we're not overstating go
read it
this is a big deal this is not a small
thing it's not renaming a post office
it's hard to believe any american would
put these ideas on paper much less
try to pass them into law and yet
remarkably that's happening and even
more remarkably
the press has ignored it this isn't
happening in secret it's happening in
the house of representatives
scores have democrats have backed this
bill
but the legislation has not been
mentioned in the new york times
has been mentioned on cnn a news channel
or even in self-described conservative
outlets like national review no mention
consider if this were working the other
way if a loan i don't know republican
state legislator from minot north dakota
had proposed to build this extreme that
would remake america completely
the president himself would be expected
to answer for it cnn would demand that
he
disavow it even if he'd never heard of
it before
but when one-fifth of the entire
democratic caucus backs a bill
demanding that you import illegal alien
felons and then pay for it
it's a non-event in the american media
they don't think you should know about
it
and that's dangerous if we're being
honest whether the press
cares or not these are the stakes of the
2020 election
and you have a right to know what they
are a growing wing of the democratic
party views america itself as
essentially illegitimate
a rogue state in which everything must
be destroyed and remade
our laws our institutions our customs
our freedoms our history our values
and of course that's the point of all of
this an entirely new country in which
resistance is crushed
and they're in charge forever